now watch this video and prepare to be
sickened
Oh Timmy just cover kicked up in dad
I'm getting this alive I'm getting this
live know what
as people have been charged in
connection with us attack we can't go
into any detail but this highlights a
simple stark uncomfortable truth we've
slid from being a have a go society to a
walk on by society to a pointer camera
and laugh society as someone witnesses
of tack on a serving police officer
Metropolitan Police Federation Chairman
Ken Marsh has questioned whether his
colleagues can even tackle violent crime
if we the public choose to snicker at
their plight now he doesn't expect you
and me to necessarily pitch in often
we'd probably do more harm than good but
so at least provides support and of
course he's right but ask yourself this
why has the relationship between the
police and those who need to be police
deteriorated to this extent well partly
because the respect has gone and virtue
signaling stunts by police such as
blokes wearing high heeled shoes to show
support for anti-slavery campaigners
have had a corrosive effect equally the
fact they often don't even turn up for
burglaries doesn't help but they need
and indeed deserve our support anything
less is no laughing matter
well when I first saw that video I had
to watch it again I was in a state of
disbelief and shock I've had my
difficult years as a teenager but never
have I seen police officers treated in
that way and I think that video depicts
the best of the worst of our society and
the first thing that came to my mind
when I saw it was Stanley Kubrick's
Clockwork Orange and the lawlessness
that prevailed in that film and the best
what I mean by the best and the worst of
our societies you've got course the
people that have been arrested and so we
won't say then he got to go from worst
to best you've got the police officers
the female police officer trying to do
her duty to assist her colleague and
putting herself at great risk and then
you've got this kind of almost sexually
aroused voice they're enjoying the scene
as she's kicked in the face and then
nearly gets hit by the bus and you hear
his voice in tone increase with
excitement it's disgusting what why
would someone isn't what yeah but why
would you not either assess the idea of
getting involved or use your mobile
phone to call for backup I mean is the
respect from that you then even get
another example of heroism because not
only is it the female police officer but
a guy gets off his motorbike and then
does go in to help her so he
demonstrates the courage jeez that the
video as well yeah but they managed to
arrest the guy off it but but the video
dude I mean you're right why didn't he
call us
emergency services he's just sitting
there enjoying the whole spectacle there
is in some people a fight-or-flight
aspect of them why some people would
never be able to get involved
no they simply want better they'll just
freeze what open oh so I understand why
some people can't get involved in in
that respect but the guy laughing in the
car is as spineless as the Geezer or
whatever it was throwing the kicking
that it's absolutely it's unacceptable
he could have included this film I
believe it'll fly I believe there's a
community spirit which is not here
anymore
if you think back to when we was kids
you know you knew you knew the person
that run the corner shop you know if
somebody burgled it affected the whole
community
okay there's too many people just out
for themselves nowadays take a step back
take a step around your surroundings you
know it just we don't treat ourselves as
a community anymore do you know it just
isn't there it just simply isn't there
I think that this speaks to the sort of
the bigger issue that we have with
violent crime amongst our young people
in general I do think that there is
something there is something that has
broken down in terms of the way that
young people value our police service
but also the way that young people from
certain communities value their role in
society the police in any way they
brought this on anyway these haven't
helped in terms of how certain
communities have been targeted but I do
think that this is a bigger issue so
when you look at the young person that
was filming the video the fact that he
was filming and then actually put that
video online which is how people read
was just find it it just shows you that
there's something that's gone seriously
wrong when I can buy a computer game
which depicts a man running around
smashing people anybody fell in the head
okay and I don't think that kids will
stay in and they will play a game where
they can run ministry and smash people
the more they do it the more they get
rewarded for it is it may be helpful to
have a pick out a few key stats which
are all that I mean I won't go do the
numbers but police funding is at its
lowest level for since records began -
no no wait wait wait
and don't say peace peace staffing level
which means that of meanwhile there are
72 assaults a day on policemen that's
one over twenty minutes one over twenty
minutes and seven twenty six thousand a
year 21,000 officers down since 2010
funding is down by 18 percent this has
got to have an impact on the street
effect respect to the police I'll tell
you why there's a sense of there's a war
by society because of all his old game
there are fewer British soldiers now I
think since the days of Cromwell also
but I respect blokes and women who do
his promise nothing to do with this and
I want to tell you something I think may
underpin a bit of it 78% of people had
confidence in their local police forces
in England and Wales
I'll tell you something I was burgled a
couple of months ago
crying the police they were very helpful
they gave me a police crime reference
number so I could get insurance get my
locks changed all the rest of it they
were very efficient right within two
days it's a standard letter yes saying
they would not they would not
investigate the crime where people when
they're seeing police officers under
attack I think it's a great laughs to
film it and this is a point under it's
not just one change you get the officers
now but if we know they can't finish on
one thing the reason why people don't
get stuck in and they're not more have a
go heroes it's because I sometimes see
somebody dropping litter and I want to
run after them and say pick it up but I
don't explain the guy laughing because
it is now bear mine police officers a
member of societies as well right so
that they're they're us they're not some
alien breed and we used to have a
respect for them and sadly and to a
degree they've worked they've brought
about their downfall I remind you up
because I'll tell you Robert Peel who
set up the police force almost 200 years
ago wrote nine principle points of
policing people like Bill Bratton the
famously successful American Police
Commissioner he kept this in his wallet
all the time
item number five these are the this is
two hundred years ago the police seek
and preserve public favor not by
pandering to public opinion but by
constantly demonstrating absolute
impartial service to the law all the
time they're wandering around painting
their fingernails because they're
showing you know the respect okay riding
the dodgems floats wearing high heeled
shoes wearing panda mask the respect
goes to justice I'm sorry that's where
the respect goes but I think back to
Rachel's point that actually the cuts do
have an impact because you know no let
me finish
because you do have less bobbies on you
don't see them
where you actually know your local
there's no there's no respect from day
one kids in most schools can say what
they like to their teachers I just say
just back check their head teachers no
one gives a flying Fig about it so when
they see police officer they treat them
the same way when it was an interesting
point from you there is you don't know
your local Baltimore though and that
does ever part to play the old Bobby
used to come around he speak your old
man he's been out of order sort him out
that don't know more there ain't none of
that anymore do you know I mean they're
just you know you more likely to get in
a small town which running is my top in
a minute
can I bring in a quote from Steve house
the Assistant Commissioner of the Met
and he says whilst officers should never
expect to be attacked as part of their
job a core part of officer safety
training is ensuring they know how to
respond to volatile situations
officers are also issued with personal
protective equipment to help protect
them and the public I am mindful that
members of the public do not have access
to such items and while any officer
would be grateful for the public to a
system with a difficult arrest they
should only intervene if they can do so
what would you have done Nick you'd be
instructing that absolutely I'd like to
think but until it happened I'd in it
until the push becomes a shove we will
just never know what each individual run
is time would do